la psoriasis es una enfermedad en la que
el sistema inmunitario ataca por error a
la piel esto provoca parches elevados de
piel inflamada con escamas plateadas
no hay cura para la psoriasis
pero hay tratamientos que pueden hacer
que sus síntomas sean menos graves los
tratamientos pueden abarcar medicamentos
que puede aplicar a la piel
y medicamentos que puede tomar en forma
de píldora o inyección foto terapia o
una combinación de estos
en el caso de la psoriasis leve su
médico puede aconsejarle que utilice
ungüentos o cremas medicinales para la
piel estos medicamentos para la piel
pueden ayudar a hidratar la piel para
mantenerla suave y aliviar la picazón
reducir la inflamación
ralentizar el crecimiento de nuevas
células en la piel y hacer que el
sistema inmunitario sea menos activo
en casos más graves el médico puede
aconsejarle que tome un medicamento en
forma de píldora o que se inyecte
otro tratamiento que su proveedor de
atención médica puede aconsejar es la
fototerapia la luz ultravioleta del sol
de verano tiende a mejorar la psoriasis
salir al exterior por un lapso breve
puede ayudar pero asegúrese de usar
protector solar para evitar daños en la
piel la fototerapia también incluye
otras fuentes de luz ultravioleta como
unidades de luz artificial y láseres
si tiene preguntas sobre los
tratamientos para la psoriasis hablé con
su médico